So this movie is based in,
uh,
in no small part on your
own life experiences.
It is a adopting and actual
you adopted like a full family,
three him and children. Wow. Wild.
That's a, that's a bold maneuver,
sir. Yeah. What were the ages? A six,
three and a year and a half. And Wow.
Yeah. What was the process?
Um, well it starts,
and this is how it starts in the movie as
well. My wife and I for years, I didn't,
I wasn't making any money and including
when after I made sex drive and, um, I,
uh, so I didn't really feel like
I could afford to have kids.
So whenever we talk about it, I just be
like, you know, not there yet. And, uh,
and then finally, um, when I
felt like I was doing better,
I was starting to get a career together,
I just started to feel like I was going
to be one of those old dads, you know,
like by the time the kid was a teenager,
I wasn't going to be able to play with
them during old, you know, I'm 49 now.
I was 41 at the time. And, uh,
so God, is that right? Oh Man.
It's depressing. Anyway, uh, so I, I, uh,
I made this dumb joke to
my wife. I said, look,
why don't we just adopt a five year old?
It'll be like,
I got started five years ago and I'm like,
I'm right back in the game.
And she was like, you know, that's
actually a really interesting idea.
And I was like, no, I'm totally kidding.
Didn't mean anything by that. And,
and then she went to a website and she
showed me the website and then when I saw
the website, I was like, oh wow. You
see these kids, you see their faces,
you start to learn a
little bit more about it.
And we just started having conversations
and it, it went from there. Now,
now I got three kids in a movie.
And they're all siblings. Yes.
So they're all came from one mom.
And what is,
how do they get separated from the family?
Um,
I don't have a lot of details about that.
You know, they don't really tell you,
you know, you, you know a little bit, but
not much. I mean, I know that there was,
that there were issues with drugs and I,
and I think there was some kind of a
fire at some point, but it's all pretty,
pretty sketchy as far as what you hear.
So you've learned a lot
about the kids themselves,
but not that much about the situation.
And what,
what made you want to
turn this into a film?
Like I would imagine that's a
very personal experience. Yeah.
Um, it was actually my
writing partner, John Morris,
because I had been about three years into
it at that point and the beginning of
it was a nightmare. Like, like epic,
bad decision. Why did we
ever do this? Yeah, it was,
it was really a nightmare
for a short time.
And then when it came online
and we became a family,
it really became the best thing that
ever happened to me. And you know,
when John and I get together every day,
we just talk about our lives a little bit.
That's how we get started.
So John had been hearing all these
stories and one day he just said,
I don't know why we're not doing a movie
about this because nobody really knows
how this works when you go
into foster care to adopt kids.
So we started talking about it and then
there was the conversation of whether it
could be a comedy or not because
that's what we do. We make comedies.
John again was like, most of the
stuff you've told me is really funny.
So not all of it of course, but that's,
and then we thought, wow, you know,
we could approach this as a comedy
and we might be able to get, you know,
a more general audience to get their,
their interest in it that way because
it'll feel less scary because that's the
problem is that most movies that are
made on this topic just frightened people
and they make people think
that these kids are all,
are all damaged and reachable of thing.
You know?
Do you worry that it would be locked
that movie 101 Dalmatians at a bunch of
people start getting foster kids
now and just screw him up? Yeah, we,
well we were talking about
top gun about how, you know,
remember when top gun came
out and everybody joined
the navy thinking they were
going to fly the plane. Right. Well,
when, um, the color of money came out,
pool halls boomed across the country.
I made a giant impact on pool halls and
I won Tom cruise movie and it was just
really, a lot of people just got scammed
out of their fucking pocket money.
Some of that going on.
I think the crazy thing about
this too was that like on the set,
you realize like when you, when we're
doing this, you go like, Oh yeah,
I always thought of people
who do that. Like, you know,
they exist, but you're like,
those are nameless, faceless angels.
They're not real people. If you're like,
do you have any of your friends at top?
I'd be like,
why don't I have friends like that?
Like those are other people you know.
And then you start like on
the set there was, you know,
people visiting or consulting and
there would be like, oh, you know,
they adopted are they run some foster
care thing and then you're like, oh,
this is actually something that people
really do well. Even like dudes,
the crew that somebody would come up,
you know,
who's in the electrical department
and be like, oh hey bro, I got,
I adopted two kids by the way, if
you like really, you know, or hey,
I got adopted when I was four years old.
Did you just would like,
once you see it now,
everywhere people are hitting me up.
Someone hit me up yesterday.
Like,
my sister is adopting four
siblings this week. Wow. Yeah,
it's nuts. I mean like, it's like
something, and I don't want to,
it's almost like when your friend gets
a car and then you start seeing it
everywhere.
Exactly like that though.
Um,
we talked about that video that went
around online of this little girl that
realize that she's opening up a box and
there's something in it that tells her
that she's been adopted by these two
people that are with her. And it's really,
yeah, it's impossible to not cry. Yeah.
I mean if you have any hard at all and
you watch that little girl freak out and
it's,
it breaks you up.
I think that's almost the test as far as
what you were talking about, about how,
cause believe me, I test if you're a
piece of shit or not. When you watch that.
Yeah, we should show that to a
lot. What's your reaction? Oh,
you're a piece of shit. You're a
sociopath. Yeah. But no, I mean there,
is that what you were just getting at
as far as, believe me, I'm not that. Hi.
That like I didn't feel special or like
any one of those sort of heart of gold
angels.
You know,
we have a line that's in the movie
where mark just says that's for the,
the kind of people that volunteer. It's
not even a holiday and we don't do that.
Yeah.
You should probably tell the audience
that I'm not staring in this movie right
now for people that aren't,
you know, those people are
like, so Tom starts in snow.
It's Mark Wahlberg movie for like
four and a half minutes. There you go.
And then everyone is mark Walberg
Stars in the rest of it. That's true.
That's a good way of breaking it down.
It was only probably like 90 minutes,
so that's pretty good. That's not bad.
What I have probably like seven scenes.
That's good scenes that now you've got
a solid presence. He didn't make it up.
You don't make the poster. The poster,
the poster. You made the standee though.
Did you know that there's a standee
in movie theaters and you're in that.
Oh really? All right. I'll take
that. Can Steal one. Heard that word?
Standee standees. Those are the
big cardboard. It was never cost.
Those things were because I didn't know
that either. Cardboard cutout thing.
That's what I always call it
cardboard cutout. Standee is the real,
the real terms that determine the
industry. That's an industry term.
That's a real.